وهذا الموضوع نتابعه في وقفه مع الحدث مع
خالد الغرابلي اهلا بك خالد لماذا يقوم
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
بتغيير وزير الدفاع لان هناك مشكله ثقه
تتعلق بالفساد هناك انتقادات محليه
انتقادات محليه وهذا في غايه الخطوره لانه
في نهايه الامر ان لم يثق الاوكراني في
المؤسسه العسكريه كيف سيمنون قياده هذه
المؤسسه على ارواحهم هم يذهبون ليقاتلوا
تحت امرتها ان لم يمنو على اموالهم ويرون
ان هناك فساد ويتم سرقات لهذا المال كيف
سيمنون هذه المؤسسه على المال هذا طبعا له
تاثير على استمراريه تقدم الشباب للتجنيد
وبالتالي هم هم العنصر الاساسي في
المعركه بالنسبه للخارج ايضا هناك
انتقادات انتقادات من دول اوروبيه
انتقادات من جانب الامريكيه الدول المانحه
والدول المانحه عندما تقدم المساعدات ان
كانت سلاح او مال للجانب الاوكراني هي
تقتطع هذه الاموال من موازنات بلادها يعني
هي اموال شعوبها تقدمها لاوكرانيا لانها
ترى ان اوكرانيا تقوم بمعركه وهناك مصالح
وتريد ان تنتصر اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
ولهذا تساعد اوكرانيا لكن كيف ستساعد
اوكرانيا وهناك من الاوكرانيين لا يساعدون
بلادهم عندما يعرف ان هناك قضيه فساد مثلا
تتعلق ببيع الاسلحه المحليه او شراء
الاسلحه المحليه او قضايا فساد تتعلق
بشراء المواد وينيه للجيش
باسعار ضعف او اغلى بثلاث مرات من الاسعار
الموجوده في السوق يتسائلون لماذا اذا هذا
من ممكن جدا ان يطرح السؤال لماذا اذا
سنستمر في تقديم مساعده لاناس يهدرون
الاموال بهذا الشكل وبالتالي استمراريه
المساعده قد تتاثر شروط الالتزام التي
تفرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي لان اوكرانيا
تريد الانضمام من الاتحاد الاوروبي وهناك
معايير معينه يجب احترامها كل هذا ددفع
اوكرانيا ل ان تتخذ اجراءات وهناك حتى لو
كان اولسكي ريزنوف نفسه لم يتهم ولم لم
يتهم بشكل مباشر ولم تكن هناك تحقيقات
بشانه لكن هناك كثر من المؤسسه العسكريه
كانوا وجهت اليهم اتهامات مؤخرا زيلنسكي
اقال ضباط التجنيد لانهم كانوا يطلقون
رشاو هناك رئيس لمحكمه العليا او رئيس
رئيس محكمه يوجه اليه توجه اليه اصابع
الاتهام بالفساد نائب وزير سابق مدعي عام
مدير عام للاستخبارات اذا الاتهامات
ملياردير وصف انه مقرب من زنسي الفساد
موجود والفساد يقود الثقه ان كان من جانب
الشعب او من الدول التي تقدم الدعم وفي
النهايه عندما يكون هناك فساد لا تكون
هناك ثقه في الاشخاص ويكون هناك تراجع في
فعاليه هذه هذه المؤسسه العسكريه
والامريكيين والاوروبيين يرون انه على
الارض هناك لا يوجد فعاليه كافيه في
الهجوم المضاد الذي يقوم به الاوكرانيين
وهم في النهايه من ناحيه عسكريه يحاولون
اعاده ضبط الامور ومن ايضا ل مواجهه
الفساد لضبط هذه المؤسسه هناك ضغوط ان كان
امريكيه او اوروبيه يبدو خالد ان لا لوزير
الدفاع الجديد روستوم اوميرو لا خبره
عسكريه له بالتالي على اي اساس جرى
اختياره هناك العديد من الدول التي لا
تهتم بان يكون وزير الدفاع رجل عسكري على
اعتبار انه هذا المنصب من الممكن ان يكون
هو اداء سياسي اكثر منه بعض الدول تفضل ان
يكون رجل عسكري ويكون مشارك في تقييم
الامور مع القيادات العسكريه ورئاسه
الاركان لكن في الحاله الاوكرانيه واضح ان
حتى ريزنيكوف هو في النهايه الوزير السابق
الذي تم تغييره هو كان محامي فبالتالي هو
بالاساس لم يكن رجل عسكري هناك ثقى ربما
في قياده الاركان وفي القيادات العسكريه
الاخرى وهناك الوجود الغربي من ناحيه
الاداره العسكريه مع الجانب الاوكراني لكن
هو يريد اوميرو ليلبي كل نقاط النقص
التي تجسد المشكله المشكله هو انه لا توجد
ثقه في في المؤسسه العسكريه لانه في هناك
فساد على الاقل لدى البعض ليس ل الكل اذا
هو جاء برجل هو كان رئيس صندوق املاك
الدوله ماذا هو ماذا صندوق املاك الدوله
صندوق املاك الدوله هذا الصندوق الذي كان
يشرف على عمليه الخصخصه يعني بيع مؤسسات
الدوله للقطاع الخاص ومثل هذا الصندوق قد
تكون هناك في امكانيه للفساد كبيره وقبل
ان ياتي قبل ان يعين اوميرو على راس هذا
الص الصندوق كان هناك شبهات فساد لهذا
الصندوق لكن عندما جاء او ميروف ضبط
الامور واصبحت تهنى تقدم التهاني ل
لاوكرانيا من قبل الحلفاء على حسن اداره
الصندوق يعني الرجل يتمتع بمصداقيه
النزاهه اولا يتمتع ايضا بخبره تفاوضيه هو
كان من كبار المفاوضين فيما فيما يتعلق
بالمفاوضات مع الجانب الروسي
لتسيير السفن التي تنقل الحبوب الى الخارج
يتمتع بقدره تفاوضيه يتفاوض ايضا كان من
المشاركين في عمليه التفاوض فيما يخص
الاسرى مع الجانب الروسي طبعا هي قضايا
وطنيه وتظهر ايضا قدره تفاوضيه كل ذلك
يعطي مصداقيه لهذا الرجل يقول ان هناك رجل
نظيف ياتي يتراس مؤسسه يفترض ان يعيد
اليها المصداقيه بالاضافه طبعا الى انه
بالاساس من القرم وقد تكون هي رساله ايضا
من زيلينسكي للجانب الروسي بانه ان قمتم
بضم القرم وتعتبرها اراضي روسيه ها هم
ابناء القرم يقاتلونكم اي انهم يرفضون
وسيعملون هم من سيقاتلون حتى يستردوا هذه
الارض وهو طبعا يعلم جيدا ان عائله اوميرو
بالاساس كانت تعرضت له من مواليد
كازاخستان ورحل اهله بعد ذلك الى القرم
وتعرضوا لنوع من الظلم وبالتالي هو يراهن
ايضا على وبتالي كل هذه العناصر تجعل ان
الرجل الذي تم اختياره يفترض على الاقل من
الناحيه النظريه سنرى عمليا لاحقا من
ناحيه النظريه يلبي الحاجه التي يحتاجها
الان شكرا جزيلا لك خالد الغربي كنت معنا
في وقفه مع الحدث شكرا لك